hey everyone it's me your friend Matt
they just filled the episode of whine
about it so I'm trashed legally speaking
in case you hadn't heard I'm nominated
for a People's Choice Award for favorite
social media star which means you have
to vote for me if you want me to win
which you should because I deserve this
so to help you make your decision I put
together a list the top 10 reasons I
should win a People's Choice Award
all right here we go one so I could go
to the awards and I can meet Meryl
Streep and then I could convince her
that we should live together cuddling in
our goose feather bed and our cottage
down by the river too so I can use it as
a pickup line at bars and then I can
have something hard to hold on to at
night when I get rejected three so I can
cut in line at McDonald's because fact
every award winner gets to cut to the
front of the line at McDonald's they can
order whatever they want your nice big
Donald's and they'll tell you Matt can
come to our store whenever he wants he
can cut to the front of the line if he's
an award winner which I plan on being
for so I can use it to cut my fine
cheese or to stab someone five because
Justin Timberlake's shouldn't have more
Awards than me all right if we're being
honest here it's time that we even this
[ __ ] out Justin I'm sick of it six what
happens if I guard the bathroom at the
award show and Chris Pratt sees me and I
don't have an award and then Chris Pratt
is like who's this loaf of Wonder Bread
without an award seven so I could tell
my doctor that I've been drinking a
whole bottle of wine a week and it's not
an unnecessary medical
they're on my path to self-destruction
eight so I could wear fancy dress in
heels and I then I get on stage in the
fashion police is like who is she but
it's made nine so I can meet Zac Efron
and convince him to let me sleep at the
end of his bed and ten visit I don't win
I'll stop making videos I swear to god
I'll shut this [ __ ] down so fast if I
don't win you watch me I'll put an end
to it and that's why I should win a
People's Choice Award for favorite
social media star thank you for watching
I'll see you next time
burn up up up up but up up a number